[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
espn's paul feinbaum joining us the
voice of the sec
and uh
scc network uh beginning at three
eastern uh paul will be on the uh sec
nation live saturday at two eastern on
sec network ahead of the sec title game
paul joins us now can you remember a
week
of coaching changes that rival this in
recent memory
no uh because there's never been one
like this dan and i was thinking to
myself it's thursday
in the craziest week we've ever covered
in college football
what if after the game saturday night
nick saban announces he's retiring and
lane kiffin takes his place would that
top everything else
[Laughter]
now you're not reporting them
no no no please okay
i was just i was just free associating
is there any is there any chess move
left
uh that could obliterate a you know a 35
year old taking over at notre dame the
two moves that we've obsessed over since
uh monday and sunday and monday and and
that's really about it uh beyond that uh
it's it's the craziest week ever who had
the best week lincoln riley brian kelly
marcus freeman
others
i i think in some ways southern cal did
with lincoln riley because you know they
have this gold-plated program that has
been dormant since pete
carroll and they have infused energy in
a town that as you know needs needs buzz
needs sizzle and he's done it i think he
will recruit fabulously well out there
there's so many great players that are
everywhere uh from alabama to ole miss
to oregon and you can you can find a
million other ones in between
uh
i i think you know notre dame is is is a
puzzle because so little is known about
marcus freeman and he hasn't been
announced yet but he likely will uh
they're just making sure that he hasn't
done anything on his resume like george
o'leary 20 years ago that's the only
reason i think they're still waiting up
there and i don't i don't blame anyone
for taking your time uh i think lsu did
well i mean brian i talked to ryan kelly
yesterday as i know you did and
he's the most relaxed 60 year old in
america he just he just uh he just
cashed in his 401k
uh for 100 million dollars and uh
and getting gets introduced to uh cajun
food
does he know what he's getting himself
into
i think on one level he does i i don't
think he understands
the lingo and frankly there's no way you
can i i've lived in louisiana and it's
it's an incredible place but the only
guy who i think ever really understood
it
is ed o'giron and he just got fired so
i think you almost have to throw that
out nick saban look
lost uh 18 years ago when he parachuted
in there from east lansing remember the
famous story dan they sent the plane for
his staff and saban's the only guy that
got off
nobody else was leaving with him
uh eventually a few more joined them but
uh
it's just that's just the way it is and
and i think fit is is overrated uh a
little bit as soon as you can start
winning fans
will love you they don't care who you
are where you're from
yeah you start to figure this out you
look at it like the immediate success i
i like what notre dame did if it meant
you kept your offensive coordinator and
basically your defensive coordinator and
they're young 35 and 29
um it can be dangerous because now if
marcus freeman becomes a head coach
everything that that entails
and i always go back to
bill belichick's coaching tree you know
charlie weiss he's not a head coach
assistant coach romeo cornell assistant
coach when you take over the head
coaching job and you're at a franchise i
mean this is a notre dame's a franchise
it's like duke the yankees the cowboys
you're taking over
something really enormous and really
really polarizing is there any other
place
in college football that comes close to
what the responsibilities will be at
notre dame
well probably alabama um but but i think
that's a given yeah and and again i know
a lot of young people are listening and
they're going notre dame uh what's the
deal but but but dan when when we grew
up
notre dame was the biggest name in
college football and it still is on one
level now
i i think it's changed a little bit
because the the sport has mostly moved
south in terms of a recruit where where
recruits want to go but it's it's
you'll never go wrong saying i just
committed to notre dame
we're talking to paul feinbaum host of
the paul feinbaum show on espn radio uh
let's look at the what-if scenarios here
if
you want to start with alabama and
georgia can alabama i know they can beat
georgia of course they have a chance but
the likelihood that we could see alabama
upsetting georgia is what
i i think it's pretty low
dan and uh
you're talking to somebody who's spent
most of his life in alabama and not not
that our predictions matter but i will
give you a stat i have not picked
against alabama
since the iron bowl in 2010 when cam
newton was the auburn quarterback uh and
by the way uh
they've only been an underdog one time
since then so it's not like i'm i'm
really doing anything or going against
vegas you you would be very wealthy if
you had bet on alabama every game uh
over the last 11 years but it's hard for
me to buy into
well nick saban's on the sidelines okay
well he was on the sidelines at college
station he was also there last week at
auburn when alabama should have lost so
i just don't think the matchup goes very
well uh and yeah i know kirby smart's
team with georgia is in the playoffs but
they don't care about that i mean they
want to beat alabama
kirby smart can't walk down the street
without somebody saying
how did you blow the last three alabama
games uh two of the two of them uh in
the national championship game he had a
he had a i think a 13 point lead the
next year in the sec game i believe he
had a 17 point lead and he he led in in
the most recent game a year ago so he
he's had enough of that and he's ready
to plant his flag i think in nick
saban's throat where do you think we get
the potential for biggest surprise this
weekend
well i do think cincinnati is vulnerable
against houston that's a team that we
just
you know we we've we haven't talked much
about but they're on quite a hot streak
uh
i i'd rather not say this out loud that
that what if
michigan lost because you know i mean
i i don't even i'm not getting out of
bed sunday morning if michigan loses
because i don't even want to think about
that possibility because i i've now i'm
now the biggest jim harbaugh fan in
america i hope he wins everything never
loses another game wait wait wait wait
what happened that sounds like that's
tongue-in-cheek paul
well it's somewhat tongue-in-cheek but i
i've heard from so many good-natured
michigan fans this week that that are so
well-meaning that i i just don't i'd
rather not deal with them again i say i
listen uh yeah
harbaugh's a is a chapter in many many
books but
oklahoma state could lose i mean all
these are possibilities they're not that
far-fetched
oh man
if michigan loses to iowa
[Music]
it does
does it undo everything
no because i i think he was hired to
beat ohio state uh and and i think you
know he's got an unusual fan base uh dan
i don't need to enlighten you on that um
and and they they wanted that game so
badly uh i think that was yeah i know
they'll argue but i think in some way
that's what he had to overcome i think
he'll win i i think this is a non-issue
but um please don't i mean i love being
on your show but i don't want to see
your name on my phone monday morning if
michigan loses because i'm going into a
cave
what if notre dame somehow gets into the
final four
well then marcus freeman uh gets to
become a hero what was the guy's name at
uh larry university
yeah but what about remember the member
of the ncaa basketball tournament with
michigan
uh fisher
right the guy nearly won the national
championship
it would be one of those type stories
and you know everyone who says that the
committee will go against notre dame i
think they're wrong i think they would
like to embrace this story uh with with
a brand new coach i i think that i think
the narrative is completely wrong on
notre dame what about oklahoma state
could oklahoma state get boxed out here
it's possible yes i i think cincinnati
is in i think all these uh doomsdayers
who think the committee will go against
cincinnati don't don't understand the
politics of this and now i sound like
one of those critics who who claim the
mother ship makes every decision they
don't uh but but i think cincinnati is
is is the favorite son here they
if they win they're in oh you think that
they cause i thought
they if they keep them at four
then it's easier to drop them out if you
know style a point style points here
i'm overthinking this as i always do dan
but i just think that
it would send such a bad message
and i i i don't you know when these
committee guys uh say oh we just we hit
the reset button every week i i don't
really believe that i think if they want
if they didn't want cincinnati they
would have kept them below that line uh
because
there would be quite a reaction uh and
that's not really well right now college
football doesn't care all they care
about is a hundred million dollars uh a
coach so but i i'm i'm pretty firm on
cincinnati getting in does nick saban
get a raise he should uh and i i wonder
if you know saban's calling to his agent
jimmy sex and going does somebody want
me i'm i'm available for 150 million and
by the way uh dan nick saban is worth a
hundred million dollars a year forget it
for 10 years what he's done for college
football for his his school his league
yeah you put nick saban uh as a ceo on
on wall street or or or california tech
company he's making uh with stock
options he's making 100 million dollars
a year easy
yeah i just wonder
how long he wants to coach he did lash
out at the fan base he flirted with
texas but i don't know if that was just
to say to alabama hey understand what
you have because there are other people
who want me or do you think he got close
to taking that texas john
i think he he was close they offered him
based on what the people with whom i've
spoken uh about 100 million dollars back
then i was in 20
2012 2013.
he told me once that he did not want to
deal with the texas boosters meaning
that there's too many people uh when he
went to alabama he laid the law down i'm
running this program don't bother me and
that was always the problem in alabama
it's been the problem at a lot of
schools so he has total control and but
i but you know he he just turned 70. i
don't think he's ready to walk away but
he does seem a little restless this year
doesn't he
yeah he he's kind like irascible
sometimes he's cranky and he just
doesn't want to deal with you know us
minions there i asked brian kelly
yesterday if notre dame was ranked third
would he have left for the job at lsu
and he said i can't answer that
what do you think he would have done
i think he would have had a difficult
time doing that um because you know
it would have it would
it would have been
perceived as unconscionable it's much
easier leaving when you're fifth or
sixth but it's no longer your
responsibility do you think that he's
basically said to the university and to
his players yesterday or monday
i can't win a national championship
that's why that's exactly right
that's exactly what he's saying and and
he's right yeah
and for all the criticism he has gotten
you know losing to alabama by 28 in 2012
and and the two playoff losses
the the roster i'll never forget on the
field in miami then you were down there
i remember seeing you at a restaurant
the night before i was walking around
with uh somebody from the nfl an nfl
executive and he said these two teams
don't even look the same uh alabama
looked like an nfl team and notre dame
looked like a a good college team they
were they're not comparable and i think
that's why he doesn't get the credit
that he really is deserving and there
was no way he's ever going to get the
five-star defensive players up there and
the elite athletes that wide receiver
and and running back and quarterback
that alabama georgia and a lot of the
schools in the south including lsu get
and that's why marcus freeman if he
takes over the job it's still the same
requirements restrictions hurdles at
notre dame
nothing nothing really changes i mean
you change coaches but you still have
your same offensive offensive and
defensive philosophies with those two
coaches you still have to get you have
to work really hard to get those
recruits in and brian kelly's probably
saying wait a minute i can triple my
salary yeah it's the sec they won a
national title a couple of years ago and
i don't have to worry about anything
academically where do i sign up and at
age 60.
yeah i think it's trying to say this
because we know saban won a championship
at lsu but but i have to think brian
kelly's saying to his wife
les miles and ed oger on won titles down
there i mean those guys
i mean i can do that i'm better than
those guys and and you're now defined by
a type and i think that's where he is oh
my god
yeah i haven't thought of it that way
but uh
no offense you were supposed to say no
offense to ed or les miles
with all due respect
of course of course of course uh great
to talk to you paul as always thanks for
joining us
thanks dan a pleasure that's paul
feinbaum the voice of the sec and you
can uh listen and watch paul findbomb
show on espn radio